SO LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
EVERYBODY HAVING A GOOD TIME?
FEELING GREAT?  HAPPY?  I HAVE
GOT A STORY THAT IS GOING TO FIX
ALL OF THAT.
>> A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT NEAR
DALLAS HAS BEEN ARRESTED FOR
BRINGING A HOMEMADE CLOCK TO
SCHOOL, 14-YEAR-OLD AHMED
MOHAMMED ENTITLE CLOCK OVER THE
WEEKEND TO SHOW HIS ENGINEERING
TEACH.
AT LEAST THREE TEACHERS THOUGHT
IT WAS A BOMB AND THEY CALLED
POLICE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THIS STORY IS JUST AWFUL.
THE KID MADE A CLOCK AND HE GOT
ARRESTED FOR IT?  AND LOOK AT
THIS, THEY HANDCUFFED THE POOR
KID IN HIS NASA T-SHIRT.
THAT IS RIDICULOUS AND CHECK OUT
THE BROTHER COP IN THE BACK.
HE CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT? HE IS JUST LIKE
AH THERE IT WAS, THE LAST LITTLE
PART OF MY SOUL JUST DIED.
>> SO HOW DID THE QUESTIONING OF
THIS TEMPORAL MASTER MIND GO?
>> SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
QUESTIONED THE STUDENT ABOUT HIS
INTENTIONS.
>> THE STUDENT WOULD ONLY SAY IT
WAS A CLOCK AND WAS NOT
FORTHCOMING AT THAT TIME ABOUT
ANY OTHER DETAILS.
>> Wilmore: THAT'S BECAUSE THERE
WERE NO OTHER DETAILS.
IT'S A CLOCK.
AND IT TELLS TIME BECAUSE IT'S A
CLOCK.
THIS STORY IS A GUT PUNCH, MAN.
I MEAN, I WAS A NERD.
THIS KID LOOKS KIND OF LIKE ME.
ACTUALLY, I LOOKED WAY NERDIER
THAN AHMED.
AHMED COULD COULD YOUNG LARRY'S
ASS TO BE HONEST.
>> BUT LOOK HERE IS A KID WHO
WAS DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT,
EXCELLING IN SCHOOL, BUILDING
CLOCKS IN HIS FREE TIME, THAT IS
WHAT HE LIKES TO DO, AND NEW
YORK CITY IS ABOUT TO SPEND
$80 MILLION TO GET KIDS
INTERESTED IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND HERE IS A KID WHO IS ALREADY
INTERESTED FOR FREE.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL LET ME SEE
WHAT IN CLOCK LOOKS LIKE.
HMM.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, IT MIGHT LOOK LIKE
SOMETHING JACK BAUER MIGHT HAVE
TO DISARM, MAYBE.
BUT ONCE WE DETERMINE THE FACT
IT IS A CLOCK THAT DOESN'T COUNT
DOWN HOW DOES HE END UP IN
HANDCUFFS.
>> LET'S JUST SAY IT.
THERE IS NO WAY THE SCHOOL WOULD
HAVE DONE THIS IF HE WASN'T
MUSLIM.
KEEP IT 100.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY, IN TEXAS YOU
CAN DRIVE THROUGH
CHICK-FIL-A SPORTING AN AR-15
AND NOBODY BATS AN EYE.
THEY JUST ASK IF YOU WOULD LIKE
WAFFLE FRIES WITH IT, RIGHT?
>> BUT LOOK THIS IS THE NIGHTLY
SHOW WE HAVE TO BE FAIR.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S TIME FOR OUR
NEW SEGMENT, FIVE REASONS THIS
MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
ISLAMOPHOBIC.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT
MUSIC IS.
THAT IS SO WEIRD.
I THINK IT IS MIDDLE EASTERN, I
REALLY DO.
OKAY LOOK GUYS THERE ARE PLENTY
OF VALID REASONS THIS MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN AN ISLAMOPHOBIA
ARREST.
LIKE NUMBER ONE, THE TEACHERS
THOUGHT THAT HIS CLOCK WAS A
TIME MACHINE AND THIS KID WAS
TRYING TO GO BACK IN TIME AND
PROTECT BABY HITLER.
IT'S POSSIBLE OR NUMBER 2, 1 OF
THE STUDENTS FRIENDS IS A FAN OF
THE NINETIES SLANG AND SAID HEY
THAT CLOCK IS DA BOMB, WHICH THE
TEACHERS JUST MISHEARD.
MAYBE.
ALL RIGHT.
NUMBER 3, REASON WHY THIS MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN JUST COMPLETE
100 PERCENT NO HOLDS BARRED
BALLS TO THE WALL ISLAMOPHOBIA.
THE ARRESTING OFFICERS WALKED IN
ON HIS WIFE DOING SOMETHING
UNHOLY WITH A SWATCH WATCH AND
NOW HE HAS GOT AN UNSTOPPABLE
VENDETTA AGAINST IN AND ALL-TIME
PIECES.
MAYBE?  A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY.
THAT ONE IS POSSIBLE.
THE NUMBER 4 REASON IT MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN ISLAMOPHOBIA.
WEIRD KIDS WHO ARE GOOD WITH
GADGETS ALWAYS GROW UP TO BE
SUPER VILLAINS, VILLAINS.
ID YOU NOT SEE THE INCREDIBLES?
ALL RIGHT?  IT IS POSSIBLE.
IT IS POSSIBLE.
AND FINALLY, THE NUMBER 5 REASON
WHY ARRESTING A KID WITH A CLOCK
COULD HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE FACT THAT HE'S
MUSLIM, IN TEXAS, IT ACTUALLY IS
ILLEGAL TO MAKE ANYTHING THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT TIME MOVES
FORWARD.